[Musique]
ac dida à 16h à ces guides la scène
allemand
quand je t'ai dit quoi
bon appétit
pour ça il dit bonsoir madame chen sa
vie nan shan à madame chiang mai au
dimanche soir
j'ai beaucoup pensé à toi est dit
[Musique]
parce que toi et moi nous sommes pareils
quelles que soient les décisions que
nous prenons
[Musique]
ce que nous laissons derrière nous et
comment nous les laissons
tant dans l'obscurité
un sauveur qui ne viendra jamais
[Applaudissements]
c'est un plaisir de te revoir des
proches ça fait longtemps
tu nous a
beaucoup manqué
[Musique]
roche et le carreau
le ko est proche
le chocolat n'a pas encore été livrée
nous on avait un accord vous comptez
faire quoi vous allez arrêter de me
protéger du froid de compte et madame
chaîne non non tu peux pas croquer
madame jean quoi rêvent tous